[Musique]
et c'est parti pour le speed casting de
cette 24e édition du challenge des
créateurs dix minutes pour convaincre le
jury pour présenter son entreprise et
être sélectionné pour la phase finale du
concours j'ai mis en avant que j'ai ben
surtout que j'ai il n'y a pas beaucoup
de secrétaire indépendante à la réunion
et ça fonctionne comme une boîte
d'intérim mais en même temps voilà c'est
vraiment le ça que j'ai mis en avant
j'ai envie de montrer en fait les
compétences de mon entreprise dans sa
salle devant ce challenge qui pour moi
va faire briller mon entreprise aux
côtés de du département parce que je
pense que mes produits sont là pour le
patrimoine réunionnais j'ai quand même
galéré donc j'ai jamais eu de dead
autour de moi pour pouvoir réussir un
niveau professionnel
et voilà j'ai quand même réussi j'étais
optimiste j'ai cru en moi et aujourd'hui
c'est parti cette jury composé des
membres des réseaux point chance et des
chambres consulaires vont sélectionner
les meilleures idées et valoriser les
parcours professionnels pour la
prochaine finale des l'innovation
puis le parcours également on ad pa
cours plus ou moins compliquées pour
arriver à la création d'entreprise des
beau challenge est
agréablement surpris ça va vraiment qui
permet aux
personnes qui se présentent à ce
en cours de pouvoir s'ouvrir pleinement
et on a le bonheur de rencontrer
des personnes qui ont été accompagnés
par le département à travers des outils
qui est de toute personne à créer son
entreprise pour les jeunes par exemple
le dispositif trempé d'activité jeunes
etc ces jeunes où c'est moins jeunes qui
ont créé leur entreprise aujourd'hui
sont intéressés par le challenge des
créateurs après délibération 14
finalistes sont sélectionnés pour la
finale dans cette catégorie bravo à eux
et rendez vous début décembre pour les
duels des candidats
[Musique]